it's free speech really all that
important so we are here at the
University of Michigan Ann Arbor where
the school has spent over sixteen
thousand dollars on their new inclusive
language program school basically spent
the cash and glorified sensitivity
training and students have even been
asked to sign a pledge to use inclusive
language and to help their peers to
understand the importance of using
inclusive language according to campaign
materials which includes an actual list
of unacceptable words we are going to
make a do not mock one of those got you
oh they're so stupid videos will never
do that here again the goal here was to
actually sit down and have conversations
with students on campus regarding the
First Amendment the truth is their views
on free speech or more shocking than any
sensationalism could ever hope to be
[Music]
do you penny inclusive language yeah um
yeah it's definitely definitely
something that hasn't been brought to
awareness um I think it's really great I
think it's really important to use
inclusive language because I guess the
university's trying to like stop
discriminating people by their language
skills represent myself steven crowder
doesn't like good idea bad idea okay so
it sounds good I would say it's a good
idea okay definitely because a lot of
times people will use language and it
you know they don't mean to be brass or
harsh they just don't know
[Music]
I think it makes that's a good
environment more like people don't feel
credit i like cuz it could hit like us
i'm so spot with someone see you're
right to freedom of speech is rarely
taken away by the sword surrender will
not happen the last time our end up
under the guise of making a better
country for all of us and with these
students even when given a lifeline but
the First Amendment free speech issue
free speech as long as it doesn't like
harbor another individual that's the way
I feel it while it may not cause
physical harm like a lot of people and
it does like only motion at what point
is free speech the First Amendment more
valuable than not hurting someone's
feelings where do you think that line
should be yes it depends on the person
like what you personally believe like if
you're okay with like not using certain
words or if you feeling fringe see
that's the thing
freedom of speech can not only apply to
individuals freedoms either apply to
everyone or no one otherwise ironically
enough freedom's become discriminatory
as far as balancing freedoms with what
people actually find offensive the
problem is nobody we interviewed
actually agreed on what was truly
offensive some of the words that you
can't say I'll read one you read one
gypped [ __ ] [ __ ] okay you
apparently don't play call of duty what
if I were to tell you that you just vile
or you don't even realize that you used
or dis offensive you shouldn't be saying
I did you did what offended me and I'll
tell you why insane crazy insane
these are from U of M yeah
[ __ ] illegal alien agree you my
iPhone's frozen crazy
so you're not even clear on it anymore
[ __ ] [ __ ] Oh
ghetto Oh cream ghetto ghetto yeah you
can take it obviously you're an
african-american gentleman if you read
this little negro oh good lord if I said
that I would have imagined you punch me
right in the face
no well once thoughts and opinions does
not have to be one so yeah even that
professor was offended by today's
politically correct term in African
American which means who knows maybe in
ten years that'll be hate speech I'm
being repressed which reminds me when
looking at this list of unacceptable
words did anyone else find a glaring
mistake
you're the most prejudiced racist
harming word yeah as far as a racial
discriminatory slur no buts not on there
yeah you're right
you're not gonna say why is it that you
just said [ __ ] ghetto [ __ ] rag head
but the n-word what's the word I'm not
gonna say it so even though the campus
tries to act as though words like crazy
or [ __ ] or as offensive they won't
even write let alone think of saying the
word the word oh come on
isn't that a little bit of proof that
there isn't a moral equivalency between
saying it's crazy cold or calling
someone the n-word I don't think so
because if you look at the words you
listed there like like [ __ ] is another
term for a cigarette in Europe the N
word then word like has so much
historical backing to it right that
exactly it's different yeah it's not the
same as crazy yeah now this video is
important not so you can send it to your
friends and go oh we've good through
stupid because they're not they're not
stupid and it's not really their fault
they're young and their minds are
moldable it's the fault of their
professors it's the fault of their
parents it's the fault of an entirely
liberal leaning mainstream media more
importantly in entertainment industry
but most of all it's the
both of conservatives who've entirely
conceded this territory namely anyone
under the age of 65 to the point that as
our republic gradually circles the drain
these kids have never even heard not
once an opposing viewpoint like ours how
many times have you ever heard anyone
with my point of view or ask these
questions on campus you should be able
to say whatever you want and no one
should be able to tell you different
honestly how often do you hear that
pardon my language
I guess not very often maybe people are
afraid to say that so maybe we're
talking about all different kinds of
diversity on campus except intellectual
diversity that's really interesting yeah
I guess
with the recent legalization of
marijuana and Colorado talk of ganja's
all the rage today is it harmful is it
harmless should it be legal should it be
illegal what kind of authority does the
federal government have the problem is
that a lot of information out there is
dead wrong